expected to meet you  thank you  u.s. us  personal truck has just walked across  the demarcation line that made him the  first u.s. president to visit our  country he handled our challenge looking  at this is an expression of his  willingness to eliminate all the  unfortunate past and open a new future I  just want to say that this is my honor I  didn't really expect it you were in  Japan for the g20 we came over and I  said hey I'm over here I want to call up  some chairman Tim and we got to meet and  stepping across that line is a great on  a lot of progress is to me a lot of  friendships have been made and this has  been in particular a great friendship so  I just want to thank you that was very  quick notice that I want to thank  different things and a lot of really  positive things are happening I'm here  to say it but tremendous positivity  really great things are happening and in  a lot of places but we met and we liked  each other from day one  and that was very important